seine songtexte kommst war für die alos
dach hast du auch ein paar von denen mal
will partner der die wirklichkeiten
passiert sind und wie schaffst du es
dann immer so viel humor in der
songtexte reinzukriegen hallo mein ding
ich bin ein lustiger mensch ich bin ein
humorvoller mensch teil kommt der humor
in meinen meine lieder rhein und der
darf auch nicht fehlen denn sonst hätten
wir ja nichts zu lachen auf dieser welt
ja was hast du noch gefragt du wolltest
wissen du dich auf meine texte komme und
ob die ob die nur ausgedacht sind oder
vielleicht auch meinem leben gekommen
sind
sie sind nicht in meinem leben frau
gekommen ich bin ein schauspieler und
die schauspieler sowie sie nummern sind
denken sich sachen aus- oder spielen
rollen aber das sind wir nicht locker
fragt denkst du dir web analyse von
julians blog hatte ich gepusht und fan
gemacht und was hältst du allgemein so
von ihm der julians blog hat sie mich
mit seiner web analyse durchaus gepusht
dass das stimmt allerdings haben mich zu
dieser zeit viele faktoren gepusht das
war das trailer parks einigen ist war
auch dass 247 das video dann das fehler
park album und die julians blog analyse
da kam vieles zusammen was mir ein
aufmerksamkeits schub gegeben hat und
dass das ist das ist erfreulich und
deswegen deswegen auch dank an alle die
da geholfen haben in letzter zeit viele
fenster zu bekommen welche von den alten
hasen nicht immer gut aufgenommen werden
das hast du treffend bemerkt es gibt
einen regelrechten krieg zwischen alten
und neuen fans ich bin ein freund von
konflikte lösung ich möchte dass wir
alle an einem tisch sitzen dass wir
gemeinsam einen tee trinken und das sich
vielleicht die neuen fans von den alten
an die hand nehmen lassen und zeigen
lassen was es noch so alles gibt und in
das universum erklären können vielleicht
sogar das wäre schön das wäre meine
wunschvorstellung für ein gemeinsames
miteinander so oder so far to fragt rust
reichel test 123 meine frage wirst du
dann terroristen image immer weiter
ablegen oder wirst du es lieben
aktuellen album an manchen stellen
wieder auf erleben lassen wenn nicht
sogar 13 lieder wieder komplett als
terroristen zu suchen so von pefc von pu
jo sei gegrüßt ich war als terrorist in
der maske des caliber 69 unterwegs das
ist meine vergangenheit und ich bin ein
vergangenheit liebender mensch deswegen
würde ich meine vergangenheit niemals
mit füßen treten
egal in was für räumlicher in zukunft
als schauspieler schlüpfen
der terrorist wird immer ein teil von
mir bleiben und sicherlich immer mal
wieder durchschimmern
erdmannsdorf den namen alligator
alligator bzw kaliber 69 oder dj titel
gekommen
lieber erdnuss mann ich war ein kleiner
verwirrter 16 jähriger junge
ich brauchte coolen namen ich weiß jetzt
im nachhinein nicht mehr ob sie noch so
cool sind aber sie habe ich nun mal und
ich weiß nicht mal mehr wie ich darauf
gekommen sie waren einfach da irgendwann
ich bin schweißgebadet aufgewacht die
namen waren da mehr
mehr kann ich nicht
aber namen sind namen und die trägt man
mit sich rum sowie nach oben auch über
290 frage ab welchem zeitpunkt hat für
qantas vom musikmachen legen könnt ist
halo 4 seit 92
ich habe das erkannt als ich mit
trailerpark auf tour war und wir dann
gemeinsam das album back street boys 2
gemacht haben und man gemerkt hat es
geht in eine professionellere richtung
wir verdienen alle geld und und es lässt
sich leben und man hat die möglichkeit
sich quasi rund um die uhr mit dem zu
beschäftigen was man am meisten möchte
wofür das herz schlägt nämlich musik
machen und da wusste ich dass kann
funktionieren
ok meine haare sind nicht gemacht aber
wohin
hallo alligator ich habe zwei fragen an
dich meine erste frage wäre welches ist
dein bestes beziehungsweise steckte das
liegt seiner meinung nach
egal jetzt ob es auf triebwerke drauf
ist oder ob es eines der anderen zehn
tore von ihr ist meine zweite frage
bezieht sich auf deine rap acht du hast
ja einen speziellen rap stil so eine art
schauspiel rap ich selbst bin ein
kleiner hobby rapper und orientiere mich
sehr an den rap und wollte wissen wie du
dazu steht dass du für andere ein
einfluss auf ihre lieder bist ob du da
jetzt stolz drauf bist oder auch du da
er wusste dass es mein stil ab in den
kerker mit ihm oder so auf jeden fall
bist du ein genialer künstler und ich
bin schon auf die nächsten werke
gespannt grüße aus luxemburg hat 1000
luxemburg ja danke dir für diese diese
komplimente erst mal du hast du fragen
von hinten anders gefragt was wie dass
ich mitspielen
ob ich meinen meinen style quasi
ob ich das gut finden wenn es wenn das
jemand kopiert imitiert oder sage dann
nein es ist meisterlich
ich würde niemals jemanden verteufeln
der meinen stil versucht zu imitieren
ich bin selbst jemand der glaubt dass
neues nur entstehen kann wenn man
versucht anderes zu imitieren und
dadurch irgendwie mit eigenen sachen
zusammen würfeln der weise etwas neues
erschafft deswegen ist die station etwas
ganz normales und etwas ganz natürliches
kleine neugeborene kinder imitieren auch
erst ihre eltern und werden dann zu
vollen großen tollen starken menschen
deine haare finde ich auch sehr schön
auch trotz nicht gemacht hat der bestes
lied ist natürlich jetzt wenn du mich
das jetzt so aus dem aus dem stegreif
fragt würden wir das wird mir das nicht
einfallen ich habe viele lieder gemacht
und weil ich wie schon erwähnt
meine meine musik nicht selbst höre habe
ich da natürlich auch keine keine
rangliste ich kann soviel sagen dass ich
die songs von meinem neuen album
gelungen finde und ich glaube aktuelles
lieblingslied ist bei mir der as lead
wunderschöne frau aber das variiert
ständig was mir halt gerade was mir
gerade am wenigsten zungen zum hals
heraushängt